County attach and R Romeo 84 Lima Zulu
papa how you doing hi what's going on I
can't get out of here okay I
know all right you're not hurt
no all right I'm sorry
well just making sure you're all right
me uh give me a second you you go for a
second
yeah can you just help me get this out
of here yeah we we're going to I know
we're going to wait hold on okay are you
injured no no am I looking like an
asshole yes uh just trying to figure out
how you got over here
honestly I'm trying to get get
home trying to get home
okay me just trying to figure out how
you got here I know all right I know I
was trying to go home and I where do you
live at
ma' okay where you coming from gorgus
okay
am I right in the
middle am I an asshole no I don't know
you so I can't make that determination
you can though
no can I like try it back out of here uh
you're not going to be able to get out
of here no I know it's like
I um
neutral something is it still moving oh
[Music]
yeah thank
you oh my goodness is there anybody with
that
vehle
yeah yeah we're with it on the
drive okay I believe I have a female
further down
track probably talking about
here
screaming should call
asur
hi
hello we don't handle accidents on
tracks I don't think I had an accident
on TR call for it or what I don't know
you have to call for
it we're just calling for a recer
because we got to get off track yeah can
I just like move just sit for not going
to move okay
do you have to call the
radio we'll get it off the tracks just
because train should be starting in a
little bit too no they're freezing it
that's the first thing you do joh here
no no I'm just saying in general you
know I'm just just do me a favor where
you
going grab her license registration
Insurance you want to hang out with her
make sure she didn't get
squirly
I just sit for a second hold on what are
we doing I was looking for my I'm
grabbing it for you I'm grabbing it
okay
f
Veronica is your driver's license inside
your
bag wait what your driver's
license um I have
a like the
keys your your driver's license it isn't
in your bag or no um I'm pretty sure
it's like in the keys oh it's in the
keys yeah
for
did you find it yeah I got it okay
great what the fuck is that all
about oh is it
Dax
um what's
that yeah get it off
the you want me to write it down for you
okay um do you mind if I just in the car
yeah the keys are right in the
car um yeah he said they're at least 45
minutes out yeah it's fine I would say
so all right
uh that's it that's I just get your I
told
her can we move
j
344 what's the male subject name this
first name we're not out with the
male okay so the female is in
Veronica
yes
yes yes follow me
now she okay yeah okay don't want you to
fall okay I'm good no I understand I
know be careful I know watch your foot
your fo watch your
foot go to
you going to just stand right here
moronica
okay he's going to come talk to you all
right
superhero superhero me you are yeah what
super hair are you um the kind
that doesn't die oh that's
good that's good what's the
name sweet V sweet V yeah I hear you I
hear you I know this is pretty
this is all
crazy you want you can set your jacket
up if you want it's cold out here all
right you're
welcome this whole thing is crazy yeah
it is crazy
how you doing dude hi what happened I'm
driving home driving
home I got stuck on
a that thing train track yeah the Train
drive but if you were drive you were
driving straight so how did you did you
turn to the left yeah yeah how'd you get
there though cuz I messed up messed up
yeah
where do you live
at anything you drink
tonight yeah yeah
okay I'm going to do a couple tests with
you all right okay what color is this
pen do you see it blue blue put your
feet together put your hands at your
sides for me okay do you have anything
wrong with your eyes no you wear glasses
or contacts or anything like that what I
want you to do is want to keep your head
completely straight okay and just look
at me I'm going to move the pen back and
forth I just want you to move your eyes
and your eyes only you're going keep
your head straight just follow the pen
with your eyes okay all right
ready
see the tip of the pen mhm follow with
your eyes
okay
don't come back to me sorry stare at the
stare at I know you were you were asking
me something I wasn't talking I wasn't
talking at all okay ready I'm ready are
you ready yeah okay we're ready together
ready
why are you not looking at this
sorry
you go from looking at this to bag of me
or bag ask you're asking me what's your
name Veronica am I talking at all no so
what am I asking you nothing so why you
keep saying I'm asking you something I'm
not talking I didn't you're right I'm
sorry okay just all I want you to do is
stare at this pen right here that's it
this pen the pen the blue pen
blue pen right see that tip yeah there
the tip yeah right
yep here we go the blue pen the blue pen
the blue
[Music]
pen
this one ready blue pen blue
pen one more time
ready going up ready yeah blue pen blue
pen yeah one no no no keep your head
here no we here
all right Veronica come back here for
me right here right
here okay face that car do you have
anything wrong with your hips ankles
nothing that would prevent you from
nothing performing a walk and turn test
not at all not at all no all okay what I
want you to do is
put your right foot in front of your
left foot touching heel to toe and I
want you to stand like this while I
explain this test you keep your hands at
keep your hands at your sides all right
mhm just like that while explain this
test this is a nine-step walk and turn
okay okay you're going to take nine
steps forward see this line right here
you can actually you can actually use
this line right here okay okay nine
steps forward okay don't start yet go
back I didn't tell you to start yep go
back sorry so put your right put your
right foot in front of your left foot on
this line you ready ready I'm going to
take three steps forward to explain this
test but you're going to take nine all
right just just like this one
2 3 you're going to take nine at at your
ninth step you're going to take a small
series of steps around around come back
to the starting position which is right
foot in front of your left foot and nine
heel to steps forward the other
direction okay ready one hold on I'm not
ready yet I'm not ready yet are you
ready I am not ready yet one two 3 all
the way to nine do you understand what I
want you to do do you want me to explain
it again to you no I'm going to fail and
be in prison ready okay one
two
three four five
6 7
8 9
okay how I so was a turn now you tell me
I don't know you said you knew right so
nine step hold on Veronica ready nine
steps forward turn around m nine steps
back
one
two three four five 6 7
8 9
okay um one more test nothing wrong oh
God what's that I
am failing yeah that wasn't good yeah I
know um nothing wrong with your hips
ankles right to do a balance test
no
okay again put your feet together and
your hands at your
sides with the leg of your choosing
you're going to raise it 6 in off the
ground okay you're going to look at the
tip of your toe counting out loud 1
1,000 2 1,000 3 1,000 4 1000 5 1000 and
so on until I tell you to stop okay you
understand what I want you to do yeah
okay ready whichever one you want go
ahead 1 10000 2 1,00 3
1,000 4 1,000 no I'm
failing okay do you want to try again
five no I'm failing like go back to go
back to your feet together and your hand
are your sides all right one more time
just see one more time this is
terrible here to judge I'm just no you
are I'm getting no no no judge one more
time try it again
ready one
two
no okay see that officer right there yep
just look at him for me real quick just
put your hands behind your
back
no
me
do you have anything on you that you
should not have any drugs anything
that's going to poke me stick me hurt me
anything like that
no
this bad I'm sorry this is bad okay so
right now you're being placed under
arrest of driving while intoxicated okay
I am not driving while intoxicated you
told me you were drinking I smell
alcohol on you while we're talking and
all the I just give you a f sobriety
test and you did not pass any of it okay
so what's going to happen now is I'm
going to take you in my headquarters I'm
going to wait 20 minutes and I'm going
to put you on a I'm going to give you a
breath test and we're going to go from
there and then I'll give you a phone
call and you go home do you have your
phone on you um no where's do you have
your phone on you at all no everything
is in my car so the phone's in the car
yeah can
you get her
phone I am never mind yeah come back
here my car
what
face the car nothing nothing on you
right that you shouldn't have want
me
change just change
yeah
be at
headquarters
all right have a seat right there for
me okay get in and where where would
your phone be in the car in the center
console where where would it be in the
car I don't know in my like in your bag
is there is there keys in the car
yeah